today is the last day that you can
pre-order our brand new diatom shirt at
microcosmos.store and if you do that
right now the day that the video comes
out and I know some of you are watching
it later and I'm sorry for that you
should be receiving it in just a few
weeks we will have it later on for sale
for the general population but for you
early Watchers you can pre-order it and
get it first so if you want to look like
the exact kind of nerd that you are head
to microcosmos dot store
[Music]
thank you
this doesn't look like much if he's out
on the street you'd think yeah that's
that's a bit of gravel but every day
tiny little things just like this are
raining down on our planet from space
each one is small about a millimeter
across so when they land we barely
notice but over the course of a year
each individual piece that makes its way
to Earth adds up to around 30
000 tons that's a lot of tons of stuff
that are so tiny that they escape our
notice but of course here on Journey to
the micro Cosmos these are exactly the
kinds of things that we like to look at
these are micrometeorites just a few of
millions that pass through our
atmosphere every single day most don't
survive the journey from space they
simply vaporize in our atmosphere but
those that do survive go through quite a
transformation as they soar through our
planet's atmosphere melting with the
friction of their entrance depending on
their speed and rotation and chemical
composition their shapes warp and
recrystallize into new shapes they may
become more elongated or perhaps
developed pointed shapes around their
body but from a distance they could be
anything a piece of sand or a speck of
dust so if it seems like it would be
pretty difficult to find a
micrometeorite that's because it is
James our master of microscopes received
these samples from a friend of his Scott
Peterson who has been hunting micro
meteorites for some time examining
rooftops in their relatively undisturbed
environments to see what he can find and
if you would like to see how well you
would do as a micro meteorite Hunter
here's a little test for your skills
let's say you're looking at this array
of pearly looking bits and Bobs do you
think you can find the micro media right
here you can pause take a moment
this is the micrometeorite alright so
now that you've seen one can you find
them in the next few slides we'll show
you again just pause if you need a
moment take a look and we will show you
the micro meteorites at the end start
with this and this then this and last
this so now that you had a moment to
look at them all let's go through and
see how well you did first we have the
micro media right here which looks
similar to the other pearly round things
except that it's a little less shiny and
then here the micro meteorite was right
in the middle of everything well here it
was off in the corner and our last one
seems practically impossible to
distinguish from everything else sorting
out these micro meteorites feels a bit
like trying to navigate the micro Cosmos
there's just so much to sort through it
requires patience and it requires
knowledge but at the end the result is
understanding that allows us to identify
and classify our universe so that we can
build some kind of framework to
understand it so it is weird and cool
that we can just walk around our world
surrounding by these bits of the cosmos
that past our atmosphere sort of like
it's weird and cool that we just walk
around our world surrounded by microbes
that we never see or think about and for
us as people who talk about microbes a
lot it's hard not to spend some of this
time imagining what it would be like for
our microbes to make the opposite
journey to go from our world past the
atmosphere and back into whatever is
beyond
unfortunately as talented as our master
of microscopes is he has yet to go into
space so just know that the footage
we're showing you now are not actually
microbes in space think of them more as
a Vibe a background for us to project
onto as we consider the possibilities
microbes are crafty Hardy creatures in
the billions of years that they have
existed they've managed to adapt to
countless environments and survived
Monumental shifts in climate but we also
live on a planet that has so far shown
itself to be uniquely nurturing what
about everywhere else we're not talking
about aliens though of course we could
there is a Rover on Mars right now
seeking out the possibility that life
may have existed there but we don't need
to consider aliens to imagine microbes
in space because there are microbes
there we brought them there because well
humans have gone to space and where we
go microbes go as well in our cargo our
food and of course our bodies
in 2020 researchers studying the
International Space Station found that
after two decades of humans living there
the space station itself seemed to have
a microbiome of its own made up of 55
microbial Genera an array of bacteria
and fungi and protists and other
creatures that are invisible roommates
to the astronauts and if you're painting
an image of super-powered microbes that
have been mutated into something
unrecognizable and Dangerous by cosmic
rays fortunately NASA looked into it and
they found that the microbes are not
dangerous though there were some
microbes particularly fungi that have
caused some damage to Windows because of
their unusual ability to grow on metal
and even when humans aren't being sent
to space our microbial marks can be left
on the things that we do send to space
which does pose some challenges for
example the perseverance Rover is
looking for microbes on Mars but it
needs to make sure that any signs of
microbial life it seem fees aren't
actually accidental terrestrial
hitchhikers so NASA had to build the
spacecraft while keeping it as clean as
possible ensuring that the Mars 2020
mission was launched with 10 times less
bacteria on it than the amount that live
in a teaspoon of seawater because space
might not kill those microbes for us the
ones that can form spores or cysts can
use those adaptations out in space as
well so even with the vacuum and the
radiation and the massive shifts and
temperatures some microbes can survive
in 2020 a team of researchers created
dried Aggregates of the UV radiation
resistant bacteria dinococcus radio
durans and they put them on panels
outside the International Space Station
a place where not much seems like it
should survive but after three years
they found bacteria in those pellets
that survived buried under a surface
layer that hadn't survived but was able
to protect those underneath there's
something about that about the way a
massive bacteria can be dried out and
placed in an environment so far from its
Origins that feels perfect as a meeting
of the microcosmos and the cosmos just
as micro meteorites burn through our
atmosphere and blend with our planet
microbes can find their own way to
become a part of
outside our planet
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and if you'd forgotten
about what we said at the beginning yes
today is the last day to pre-order our
new diatom t-shirt over at
microcosmos.store now that the video is
over you can just go do that but since
you stayed at the end of the video we
also wanted to let you know that you can
get 10 off our set of four plan
objectives if you want to use the promo
code plan 10 at checkout that deal only
runs through March 6th so you will want
to pick those up soon if you want to
upgrade your micro Cosmos microscope the
link for those and our diatom t-shirt
are both in the description below
thanks so much to all the people on the
screen right now they are our patrons on
patreon they are the reason that we're
able to make Journey to the micro Cosmos
and explore topics as diverse as
bacteria on the outside of space
stations and micrometeorites that are
all around us all the time that we never
even notice so if you like what we do
here these are some of the people to
thank and if you'd like to become one of
them you can go to patreon.com journey
to micro if you'd like to see more from
our master of microscopes James Weiss
you can check out jam and germs on
Instagram and if you'd like to see more
from us there's probably a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
foreign